こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと、
はいどうも水溜まりボンドです。よろしくお願いします。
トミーです。
カンタです。
ト）はいお願いします。
カ）よろしくお願いします
ト）お願いします、、
カ）お願いします。
ああ
は）今日はですね。ちょっと、お2人さんと
やりたいことがありまして
ドミノ
ト）ドミノ。
カ）ドミノ。
は）これってさぁ
並べて倒すヤツじゃん
ピッてやって（？）ポロロンって。（？）
何センチぐらい伸ばしたことあります？
ト）30センチとか？
カ）www
は）適度な距離をピンってやってポロロンってなって
イエーイみたいな
ト）はい　カ）はい
は）甘ーい！！！
ト）甘いぞ～（棒）
カ）ふざけんな～（棒）
は）ということで今回ですね
ドミノを
２０００個！準備しました
（マジカ）
は）ドミノ２つを置くとこうやって倒れるじゃないすか
パンパンって
この間の距離がだいたい
2,５センチぐらいになります。
さあ
２０００個ドミノがあると何メートルになるでしょうか？
何メートルだと思う？
カ）５０メートル
は）その通りなんですよ。
ト）ずるじゃん
は）約５０メートル並びます。
カ）50メートル走分ぐらいっていうことでしょ
ト）3人でできるんすか？それ
は）そうそれをこの繊細な俺たちでやれば？
できると思うんですよ
ト）倒しちゃったらもう本当に笑えないっすね
は）1回50メートルがどのくらいか測ってみましょう
は）立って、、なんかぐるぐるのほうがいいよね。たぶん
ト）ま、そうっすね
カ）距離的にもう
は）はい
というわけで50メートルこんな感じみたいです
ト）やばいっすよ本当に
カ）やってみるとよりやばいっす
は）やっていきましょう！！！
カ）よし！　ト）よーごー（聞き取れなかったすみません
は）とりあえず2000個出しましょう
カ）はい
ト）やばいな
は）はい、というわけでこれからこの2000個
のドミノを並べていきましょう！！！
ト）やりましょう
は）中心ここら辺にします
ト）はい、分かりました
は）よしヤります
ト）ヤりましょう
カ）イキましょう（意味深）
は）こうだよねこうだよね
カ）こうかいてんだと思っていきますよ。
ト）あ、これ全然倒す可能性あるな
は）あっあーはっはー
は）ねええ
は）今ので気づいた
は）息で倒れるこれ
は）え、トミー早っ
ト）僕頑張ってますよ
カ）ついに
は）ついにつながりポイントですか
ト）ここつながりポイントですよ
ト）カンタの作ってきたとこと僕がやってきたやつがつながりました。
お～～
は）結構ぽいよ
ト）キテますね
カ）いいですよ　いいですよ
は）は～～（あくび）
ト）バカバカバカそれはダメ
は）危なーい！
ト）それは　あー
は）はあはあはあ
ト）やばすぎ　やばすぎ　やばすぎ
カ）（そんなつもりじゃ）
ト）マジで心臓止まるかと思ったあ
カ）あざます
は）人の命救うために
ト）マジでもう
ト）あー確かにカンタのその
やっちゃったとこ修（復）
ト）はじめさん？
カ）はじめさん？
は）はあはあはあ(*´Д｀)
は）ねえやりたくなくなっちゃった
カ）やりたくなくなる
は）やりたくなくなる
ト）あっあっあ
は）ハリガー！！！
は）はあはあはあ
カ）もう！
は）ふうーー
ト）わざとやってます？
は）へっへっへ
は）ラスト！！！
皆）おおー
は）キター
は）では
カ）今日いい日になりますね
は）いい日だ
ト）ちょっとマジで怖い
は）５０メートルドミノいきまーす。
は）３
は）２
は）１
は）はい！
ト）おお？
は）あああ
は）いきます！
カ）はい　おねがいします。
ト）おねがいします。
は）３
は）２
は）１
ト）おおおお
カ）いけいけ
は）はい！はい！はい！
は）いってるいってる
ト）いいねいいねいいよ！
は）がんばれ！
ト）おい
は）あああ
カ）いきます
ト）ふはは
ト）何お前ｗ
ト）おおお　いい　いいよ
ト）そゆこと！そゆこと！
は）がんばれ！
カ）いけ　いけ　いけ
ト）よしよし　おお
は）いいよぉ！
ト）はやい　はやい　いけ　いけ
は）すごい！
カ）まわってこい　まわってこい
は）はっはっは！
は）あああ
ト）おい！
カ）何回やるんすかこれ
ト）　いい　いい　いい
ト）
ト）おい頑張って戻って来いよ
カ）いいっすねぇ
ト）あの辺いい
カ）きれい！きれい！きれい！
は）イエーイ
カ）これいきますね
は）あ、もうキタねこれは
ト）あーこれはもう乗ってｍ
ト）ハハハハ
ト）フハハハハ
ト）ちょっと待ってこれもう
は）ねーー！（怒）
ト）なはははは
は）はいok!
ト）はいokです！
カ）ドミノじゃないです。
ト）これドミノじゃないですｗ
は）というわけで今回は５０をテーマに
は）水溜まりボンドと動画を作ってみました。
は）ところで皆さん、
は）通信制限にかかってしまって
は）我慢したことありませんか？
は）みんなが思う存分楽しめる
は）そんな願いをかなえてくれるが
ソフトバンクさんのウルトラギガモンスター
は）このプランならこれまでの我慢
は）を開放してくれます！
ト）ウルトラギガモンスターは
ト）５０GBの大容量プランです。
ト）動画なら１日７時間
ト）１月でえっと２２０時間
ト）見れるので、もう動画見放題といっても
ト）過言ではない（棒）
は）すごいね（棒）
ト）標準プランの５GBのえっと
ト）プランに５００円１コイン足すだけで
ト）１０倍の50GBが使えます。（棒）
カ）サラニ今なら学割展開中で
カ）学生さんはもっとお得に使うことができます。
は）はい、というわけでソフトバンクはyoutubeや
は）youtuber好きなみんなに思いっきり
は）スマホで動画を楽しんでってほしいと
は）思っております。（読み方が棒）
は）だから大容量にこだわって
は）ウルトラギガモンスターを提供しているんです！
は）みんなもウルトラギガモンスターでどんどん
は）遊び心を開放しよう！